dans les manifestations anti-davaux sont
vois souvent des slogans contre le
nouvel ordre mondial mais qu'est-ce que
c'est au juste que le nouvel ordre
mondial
[Musique]
bonjour fade bonjour Rudy alors le
nouvel ordre mondial c'est un mythe
selon lequel les puissants de ce monde
chercheraient à instaurer en secret un
gouvernement planétaire unique avec pour
objectif de réduire l'humanité en
esclavage d'où ça vient l'expression est
née dans les années 50 aux États-Unis au
sein de l'extrême droite anticommuniste
à cette époque elle servait à désigner
un complot international crossoviétique
de domination du monde avec la
complicité des Nations unies par la
suite l'expression était chargée de
signification nouvelles on a expliqué
que le nouvel ordre mondial était un
projet de domination poursuit par les
illuminatis les Illuminatis c'est une
vraie société secrète qui a existé au
18e siècle mais qui a été dissoute à
partir des années 90 la gauche radicale
encore les sphères religieuses
intégristes se sont emparés de cette
théorie pour dénoncer leurs ennemis
politiques ces caractéristiques des
mythes conspirationnistes ça marche pour
tout le monde mais tu dirais que ça n'a
aucune réalité on a pourtant des
responsables politiques tout à fait
sérieux qui ont utilisé cette expression
de nouvelles ordres mondial ce qui s'est
passé c'est que les complotistes sont
cherchés dans la réalité les indices
permettant d'étayer leur thèse et donc
ils se sont mis à répertorier toutes les
fois ou des responsables politiques ont
parlé dans leur discours d'un nouvel
ordre mondial pour dire ensuite regardez
vous voyez bien on n'est pas fou il y a
des grands événements des séismes
géopolitiques comme la chute du mur de
Berlin en 1989 qui bouleverse le monde
et redistribue les cartes mais quand un
responsable politique de premier plan
parle à ce moment-là de Nouvel Ordre
Mondial ça n'a absolument rien à voir
avec le fantasme des complotistes
pourquoi tu lises cette expression
complotiste alors il n'utilise pas une
expression complotiste ce sont les
complot ce qui ramène tout à leurs
obsessions dans la logique complotiste
tout fait sens tout fait signe si un
président ou un diplomate utilise à un
moment donné dans un discours ces trois
mots dans cet ordre là et bien cela
devient immédiatement pour les
complotistes la preuve qu'il fait
référence à ce complot là justement ce
complot fantasmagorique on peut les
comprendre réfléchir un instant si le
nouvel ordre mondial est un projet
inavouable pourquoi prendre le risque
d'en parler publiquement le cap du
Bilderberg la Commission de la
Trilatérale réunissant les chefs d'État
ses réunions existent tout de même non
elles existent mais de quoi on parle on
parle de forme de discussion ou se
réunissent des personnes influentes
venant d'ailleurs du monde politique et
pas seulement économique scientifique
des médias sont des personnes connues
qui viennent de tous les continents
quelles preuves avons-nous qu'il n'y a
pas de décision prise il se réunissent
pour faire des choix non peut-être mais
ce n'est pas secret les organisateurs de
ces forums communiquent sur les points à
l'ordre du jour la liste complète des
participants le lieu et la date de la
réunion mais comment être sûr qu'il ne
travaille pas pour ce nouvel ordre
mondial non seulement on n'a pas
d'exemple historiques d'un complot pour
s'emparer du monde qui durerait depuis
70 ans mais surtout on a suffisamment de
recul pour savoir que tout ce que les
complotistes ont dénoncé depuis les
années 1950 sous le nom de Nouvel Ordre
Mondial c'est-à-dire l'émergence du
dictature totalitaire ne s'est jamais
réalisé
[Musique]